[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud proud proud and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
[Music]
the happiest man
in washington dc this morning
is mitch mcconnell
that's right
he
is
static about yesterday's testimony i bet
he's so excited about what was revealed
yesterday
in the january 6 select hearings that he
ate ketchup
on his scrambled eggs this morning i'm
almost positive that mitch mcconnell is
probably going to
eat ketchup with every meal from here on
out
of course you know
there's a lot of fodder on the the
tweety tweets and attorney trains we're
gonna we're gonna go through the
shitless roundup today for sure
but we're gonna talk a lot about the
hearing
uh yesterday and some of the
groundbreaking news but i want to give
you guys
a lesson here in messaging
and why the january 6 select committee
decided to make sure that the scuffle in
the beast
with the secret service
and more importantly the ketchup on the
wall was in the hearing yesterday there
is a very important reason why it was
there
the reason why is because most americans
are not
engaged with politics
if the american people the majority of
american people watch the hearings
yesterday they would have no idea who
mark meadows is
they would have no idea who cassidy
hutchinson is
they wouldn't even know who rudy
giuliani and mike pence are i i know
that i know
that sound that's crazy tony that's
crazy but they do not
they don't know
they know who donald trump is they know
he was president
and he's at the heart of all this
now the two things that the entire world
is talking about this morning are not
the crimes that were committed it is
it's not a crime for donald trump to get
irate in a vehicle
and talk about it you know talk badly
and and maybe have a have a a little bit
of a physical altercation
with his detail that's not that's not
the crime we're talking about
throwing a plate of food against the
wall
and having ketchup run down the wall
that's that's not the crime that's not a
crime and that's not the crime we're
talking about here but the most
important part
you have to remember what the select
committee's goal is here
is to expose donald trump
as the [ __ ] loser
that's the most important component of
this entire political operation and
that's right
this is a political investigation that's
what the republicans wanted why do you
think mitch mcconnell wanted this to
destroy trump
they convinced trump that y'all you
should do this in the in the guise of
politics and you'll win because you're
so great he's terrible at politics by
the way he's horrible at it nothing it
speaks more to that evidence than the
statements that he has put put out since
the hearing started yesterday he can't
stop [ __ ] rage tweeting or truthing
or lying whatever the [ __ ] it's called
over there on his fraudulent social
media site
he can't stop he can't help himself he's
a [ __ ] child we seen that in the
testimony yesterday but here's the thing
here's the most important part about the
ketchup and why the ketchup is the most
important to america i know it sounds
crazy you're like tony jesus christ he
was letting people with weapons in and
he knew they were going to go hang like
pens yeah we all know we know that
we who pay attention and who engage in
politics and know how vital it is to our
democracy understand that
but most people do not understand nor do
they want to
this is this is where we're at
the committee knows that liz cheney
knows that why do you think they put the
ketchup in the [ __ ] hearing the
reason why is because here's the story
and this is this is the story you should
be telling out in in the public to
people who don't know
trump supporters people who don't engage
in politics who knew nothing about
politics
they'll hear this story
trump is such a sore loser that he threw
his plate against the wall such a little
[ __ ] that he threw his plate against
the wall because he lost
listen to the words that are coming out
of my mouth
he is such a sore loser
they threw his plate against the wall he
was so butthurt about losing
that he threw his plate against the wall
and smeared ketchup and they had to
clean it up think about that for a
moment think about that statement think
about if that gets into the american
psyche think about is if that is the
thing that comes out of this entire
hearing
which is the aim of the political
operation that is happening inside
congress
yes it's to uncover the crimes it's to
give america the truth
but the ultimate truth is the absolute
refudiation of the big lie that's what
caused all of this
if donald trump would have conceded when
he should have or when an honorable
person would have which he's not
honorable at all not a [ __ ] not a
[ __ ] grain of rice of honor in that
[ __ ] or conscience
we've learned that over from the hearing
but what we have to get into the
american psyche what has to be pounded
into the brains of americans who do not
understand politics who do not follow it
and do not care but they vote
which is kind of weird but that's what
happens
what we have to do is have we have to
get the narrative in this country that
he [ __ ] lost and he was so [ __ ]
pissed that he lost that he threw his
plate at the wall now that's not that's
not what was testified to yesterday i
mean that's that's the underlying truth
he threw the plate against the wall
because the ag refuted that he won and
refuting what he was doing that's the he
was pissed off at bill barr
but bill barr was saying you [ __ ]
lost you [ __ ] lost stop you [ __ ]
lost your maniac
you [ __ ] lunatic
and he only proved that he's a maniac
and a lunatic because he was willing to
throw his plate against the wall like a
five-year-old
listen to me when i say this this
ketchup story is so important i know
people are like oh don't don't get
distracted by the ketchup story no that
is not the distraction
that's not the distraction that's the
rocket that you launched that he lost on
that's it that's the story otherwise it
would have not been in the hearing it
has nothing to do with the underlying
crime not a goddamn thing other than the
show that he's a [ __ ] baby that's it
why do you think they put it in there
they put it in there for american to
grab a hold of because the committee
knows this the committee knows that
americans aren't going to follow this
entire hearing they're not going to
they're not going to follow all six or
eight of these things we're talking
about
14 to 16 hours of testimony they're not
going gonna follow it they're not gonna
watch it they'll take one piece just one
little nugget
and they'll run with it but their goal
is to make sure americans know that
trump knew he lost he knew he lost and
he was a sore loser about it and the
ketchup story tells that story also well
doesn't it
so don't get distracted
by not letting america think he's a
loser
if someone's going to continue to talk
about the ketchup story
and convince average americans who
wouldn't know otherwise
that yeah he knew he lost he knew he
lost he knew he lost he knew he lost he
was such a sore loser he threw his plate
against the wall he's such a sore loser
he's such a little baby he threw ketchup
on the wall
these are the stories that are gonna be
told folks
they're not gonna tell the story about
the mags
no one knows what the [ __ ] mags are
they kept referring to mags mags mags
close the mags take down the mags let
them in
no one knows what the [ __ ] mags are they
don't know
and you standing around explaining to
them what the mags are so you can
explain the crime that happened and and
on and on and on and on and on only
gives them more reason to believe donald
trump
because you get caught in these stories
about what's real and what's not what
happened what didn't
they'll believe the story about the
[ __ ] ketchup
hunter percento
no doubt in my mind they will believe
that story
so go out and tell that story
your uncle earl
who has all the trump flags
that are tattered
because they're [ __ ] garbage flags
he's got all his shitty ass chinese-made
trump hats his trump shirts
his cut out cardboard cutout of trump on
his face
superimposed on rambo in his dining room
that guy
tell him about the ketchup story
tell him he'll know
he's not gonna believe in the other
stuff
he'll believe trump is a whiny little
[ __ ] though
and that he lost and that's the key here
folks that's the key that's the that we
have to politicize this
that's right i said it we have to
politicize every single angle every
[ __ ] one of them
with people who understand politics yeah
you can talk to mags you can talk how he
didn't give a [ __ ] if mike pence was
killed
the stuff that he told meadows and rudy
giuliani and his secret service
you can say that kind of stuff because
they're engaged they know you can
explain what the magnetic
the the the entry things are to detect
weapons and that's the reason why people
weren't coming into his rally
at the ellipse because they all had
weapons because they had to walk through
the mags and he was saying take him down
take him down take him down yeah that's
great that's a great fact that leads
right to the intent of the crime but
most people aren't gonna [ __ ] know
that
and they're not gonna wanna stand around
talking about it what they will stand
around talking about is how tom brady
rather he's going to retire or not which
team kyrie irving is going to play for
and did you hear
trump such a [ __ ] sore loser that he
threw his plate against the wall what a
little [ __ ]
you follow me
that's the aim here it's political yes
it's political that's what the
republicans wanted they wanted this to
be a political trial
you know he's acting like donald trump
is acting like this morning this is some
kind of criminal trial like there's a
jury and
cross-examination and i don't know what
the [ __ ] he's out of his goddamn mind
he's lost his [ __ ] he's a lunatic
and he's scared he's a scared little
animal
i just want to know
how much ketchup they had to clean off
the walls yesterday holy [ __ ] can you
imagine how much ketchup they had to
clean off the walls yesterday as this
hearing was going on jesus christ
they probably had to order a couple more
cases of ketchup
what do you think is it hunts or is it
heinz which one do you think it is i
don't know i don't eat ketchup [ __ ]
ketchup i'm not a ketchup person
and that's right you can judge me judge
me judge me all you want but i don't eat
ketchup
ketchup's [ __ ] gross
even on french fries that's right i said
it i don't even eat ketchup on french
fries
[Laughter]
but how much ketchup do you think they
had to clean off the walls yesterday
while the hearing was going on holy [ __ ]
the ketchup ketchup ketchup story folks
i know it's like oh my god what are you
doing what are you saying that's not the
crime yeah that's the exact point that's
the point
is it shows how much of a sore loser he
really is how pissed off he was that he
wasn't going to win that he wasn't going
to be president that's the [ __ ] point
of the whole goddamn select committee
is to deep program or reprogram this
country to [ __ ] wake up and realize
this is dangerous [ __ ]
to put someone who's so mad that they'll
throw their plate against the wall
because they didn't get their way to be
the president of the united states this
person has the [ __ ] nuclear goats
and he can't manage to hold his [ __ ]
emotion enough not to throw his plate
against the wall
and this isn't the first time
this is the first time that he done he'd
done that and it won't be the last time
either for sure
i just hope after
yesterday donald trump figures out how
to keister
heinz ketchup
a bottle of of ketchup in his ass
for when he goes in detention because
let me tell you something about
yesterday's hearing
holy actual [ __ ]
if you get past the ketchup and the
secret service talk into the crimes oh
my god
the talk from rudy
giuliani where
she was taking now remember she had
heard rudy giuliani and donald trump
talking about the oath keepers
you remember that you remember that talk
apparently flynn and stone had something
to do with the oath keeper soon
someone's been saying that on their show
that a guy named stodger roane is the
[ __ ]
is the go between the oath keepers the
proud boys and trump hmm i wonder who's
been saying that crystal ball much doubt
me
doubt me just doubt me i don't give a
[ __ ] doubt me it's stagerrone that's who
it is
that's who we're gonna find out who the
[ __ ]
is the go-between between the proud boys
the oath keepers and trump
we heard yesterday the testimony that
she
she was within
within
rock throwing distance of a conversation
where the president united states is
talking about the oath keepers with rudy
giuliani and then rudy giuliani the
other testify the the testimony that
cassidy hutchinson gave yesterday was
that she walked rudy to his car and he
was like oh it's going to be beautiful
he's going to go to the capitol
it's going to be great
they're going to march and they're going
to take over and he's going be the the
dictator king of the united states of
america even though that's not how it
works
but don't you see i've been saying it
for [ __ ] months i've been saying it
for months folks
that stuart rhodes and the oath keepers
switched the detail for roger stone from
the proud boys because they had control
of the qrf which was the stash of
weapons across the potomac and they were
waiting for trump to come down to the
capitol declare martial law so they
could lead him in and crown him king
it's all right there
it's all right there
yeah it's obvious to us
but to hear it
to hear them say it someone who was in
the [ __ ] white house
feet away from the oval office with an
earshot of the president united states
talking about the oath keepers and then
listening to rudy giuliani his lawyer
[ __ ] drunk rudy jesus christ rudy
kaluti
grandpa farty mcarty rudy giuliani
tells her
yeah it's gonna be a beautiful day on
the six he's gonna go down to the
capitol and he's gonna be crown dictator
crown king of the united states of
america some dumb [ __ ]
[ __ ] rudy's out of his goddamn mind
out of his mind
i mean it's not enough that he thought
trump could be king he thought his son
could be governor
that's another news rudy giuliani gets
his [ __ ] ass kicked
now you got to give him a pat on the
back though at least he tried
pat pat andrew giuliani on the back at
least he
tried but back to the hearing yesterday
in the testimony
the other testimony is that he knew
these people were armed
and he knew who they weren't going to
use the arms on the weapons on he knew
it he knew it he said they're not gonna
they're not gonna hurt me
i don't care what kind of weapons they
got they're not coming after me in
particular i know who they're coming
after
it's just not me
and i'm going to make sure they know who
to go after i'm going to invoke mike
pence
in the speech
i'm going to invoke going to the capitol
i'm going to stoke violence even though
the legal council says i shouldn't
because
that might put you in legal jeopardy
they knew what was going to happen folks
the writing was on the wall
or the ketchup as it were
they knew this was gonna happen
i knew it and they're already trying to
change their narrative
now you see uh i'm gonna play you a
video we'll try to find it uh stuart
rhodes calls from his j from the
jailhouse to dinesh d'souza's
show and they're already trying to
re-spend this
as the fed set this up they're all it's
a big setup it's a big setup and that's
going to be the
the talking point that's going to be
their go it's going to fail miserably
miserably it's going to fail and the
reason why it's gonna fail is because we
heard
even the police radio fodder that day
we saw the the actual radio fodder
of police officers identifying people
with weapons
with weapons
they had ar-15s they had they had
handguns and there's
in their waistbands
they had [ __ ] weapons they knew it
the secret service knew it trump knew it
not take the mags down let them bring
them in [ __ ] it they're not going to use
them on me they're going to use them on
who whomever
start [ __ ] crazy ass [ __ ]
and there's so much from yesterday that
it's hard to remember every single point
that was made
but believe you me believe you me do not
doubt the ketchup story being important
i know
it doesn't feel like it but it's
important to the narrative
it's important to get this country to
realize and to pay attention even if
just for a moment to pay attention to
why this [ __ ] why this piece of [ __ ]
should not have the nuclear codes why he
lost why we need to just forget about
this [ __ ] fat slob
because i i believe after yesterday uh
there is enough to say that yes it
definitely looks like donald trump is
going to be prosecuted
rather in georgia or in a federal court
and for january 6 or other crimes
he's going to face criminal prosecution
somewhere someway somehow
rather rather that's the exact way
that we want it as
the anti-trump wing of the country wants
it or not
he's going to be uh indicted in some
form or fashion
some form or fashion
yesterday it went from uh believing that
he could be
charged with obstruction of a official
proceeding which is
judge carter's decision about the
eastman emails
to seditious conspiracy yesterday
so
we will see where the department adjusts
and graves the united states attorney in
dc goes with this a particular case for
january 6 because that's the other thing
that i think a lot of people misread
they keep saying the words merrick
garland this merit garden that merrick
garland does not recommend charges to
himself
now the united states attorney
in dc will recommend charges to the
department of justice
for merit garland to look at and to
approve
it's graves who does the investigation
it's graves who brings the charges it's
graves who presents the evidence to the
grand jury not merrick garland
so understand the process here and
understand this is going to take a long
time we even we even
just in the last week 10 days
we
we got the notification that the proud
boys trial is pushed to december i
believe december 13th maybe 15 13
sometime in the middle of december
is when the proud boys trial will is
scheduled for now it will get pushed as
well that proud boys trial will not
happen in december it will probably
happen sometime next year
for the proud boys trial
and the reason why it'll probably happen
is there's probably going to be more
superseding indictments in that case and
they'll push the trial to push the trial
as the grand jury does more superseding
indictments here
and i like likely we really won't see
any kind of trial for the seditious
conspiracy possibly until the end of
next year
maybe maybe even into 2024
when the actual presidential race starts
that's right it's probably when we'll
see trial as long as
all these people do not plea take plea
deals which they will not all of them
will
it takes a long time to build a case
especially build a case against the
former president united states and all
his legal counsel
because you got to remember we have
jeffrey clark
who who he was trying to make his
personal attorney and his personal [ __ ]
at the department of justice by making
him a.g to crown him king
we have rudy giuliani now with a lot of
exposure because he knows exactly what
was going to go down on january 6. and
then we see john eastman
with the criminal exposure here and i
believe
those three including my plus mark
meadows
uh is the move that the next move that
the department of justice may make
i think that's the clear move here uh as
they as they have taken rudy giuliani's
devices already
they've seized
um jeffrey clark and john eastman's
devices just in the last uh couple weeks
and we we
we know that they postponed one hearing
it seems to actually collect the
electronic devices from jeffrey clark
so i believe that's the department of
justice's next move and i think
their main move is against mark meadows
here because cassidy hutchinson
is
is the voice for mark meadows she is the
witness to mark meadows she was his aide
and that was the that that was the
beginning of the hearing yesterday when
they were trying to place her in the
white house like she's not a [ __ ]
she's not just the person who goes and
gets coffee
she's standing right next to the door
she's listening to these conversations
she's in the [ __ ] rooms as this [ __ ]
is happening
they tried to make that very clear with
the map and really the map honestly it
made the white house look bigger than it
actually is because then you see you
they showed the pictures of the hallway
i think people under are uh get it
confused that the white house is really
small like it was built a long time ago
so parts of that building are really
small they didn't build it to be an
auditorium
so yesterday's hearing
the news really is
cassidy hutchinson destroyed donald
trump
and she destroyed him with the best
evidence that there is is to watch
donald trump lose his [ __ ] mind
on the internet
uh
cassidy hutchinson
she may have been able to say something
sooner
a lot of people are saying that she may
have been able to do
the right thing sooner
she apparently had a very uh
trump
trump maga attorney that was pushing her
in certain directions
she recently got a different counsel who
is pushing her in the right direction
and she's making the right decisions now
and yesterday's hearing
will be
the part that we probably remember in
history
about the entire
january 6 select hearings
is the moment when they described that
donald trump put hands on secret service
because he was so upset that he wanted
to go the capitol and they would not let
him
and also that he's such a [ __ ] loser
he's such a [ __ ]
loser
that he threw his plate against the wall
what a little [ __ ]
everyone stick around don't go anywhere
we'll be right back with the shitless
roundup when we return right after this
break
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing nancy pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi i'm paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket i've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on january 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of congress who also helped with the
attempted coup pardon blanket will
protect you too pardon blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the usa
don't delay and get your pardon blanket
today for just 99.99
actual partying is not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the tony
michaels podcast
pardon me
do you have any
ketchup
for my for my fries and steak
[Music]
[Music]
i really do think they have pocket
pardons here that that's that's going to
be the challenge that's why this trial
thing is going to take a little longer
because i really do think that he
probably wrote pardons with ketchup on
napkins before he left the white house
that's probably what happened i'm just
i'm just snowballing here he probably
took out some napkins you know the ones
that didn't have
you know
uh diet coke and ketchup stains on them
or big mac grease stains
what do you think what do you what do
you think what do you think was on the
plate that he threw against the wall
what do you think it was
i don't know i mean i'm guessing it was
probably a [ __ ] cheeseburger right
i mean to be empty or a big
maybe maybe he's one of these [ __ ]
weirdos and i'm i'm not trying to put
anyone on the spot here
that doesn't want his food to touch you
know what i mean so he's got to put his
ketchup on a different plate maybe or do
you think he actually took the [ __ ]
bottle
like the squirt bottle and just was
squirting it on the wall oh
god damn it i lost oh i gotta [ __ ]
lose
you know squirting on the wall
it wouldn't make that noise i mean if as
long as it wasn't full
which i i would bet that he uses enough
ketchup that it wouldn't be full
so
oh
boy
the tweety tweets and the trendy trends
oh my god oh my god
there's some crazy stuff this morning in
the tweety tweets and trendy trends and
there's a lot of tweets that i want to
show you
that um
people had there's some there's some
video out there that i want to show you
as well
so let's get right to it i think gabe
sanchez is going to be joining us here
in a minute well let's go ahead and
start the [ __ ] list roundup start the
countdown
[Music]
[Music]
so
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome back to the
coach of the [ __ ] list roundup this
segment gabe welcome good morning good
morning the shitless roundup already and
boy boy is there a lot of [ __ ] to round
up apparently there's some supreme court
decisions this morning as well yes there
were yesterday we also have some
election news gabe there's a lot of
election news from you
a lot of [ __ ] that happened yesterday
yeah
a lot of [ __ ] to clean up a lot of
ketchup to clean up off the walls we
need to catch up from all the news
yesterday right
i i've been making the case this morning
to the audience that i believe the
ketchup story is the story that america
will remember and everyone's like oh
don't get all caught up in the ketchup
story but i'm like no that's that's the
nugget yeah yeah i mean there's a
there's a chicken nugget that you dip
the ketchup in exactly i mean if you're
gonna have the chicken nugs you know
you're gonna have to dip it in the
ketchup
but that is one thing i've uh i made a i
made an image this morning oh and i
don't know if
the hat should say make america hines
again
or make america ketchup again
i think it's i think it should be hines
or hunts does he use heinz or hunts
which isn't that's a good question i
mean you know i i'm not a ketchup
connoisseur i [ __ ] hate it right
right so maybe i just can't i hate it
even more now but i don't know right
well i looked up the meaning of heinz
and heinz means
cooler of the home
who
it's german for ruler of the home ruler
of the home well that makes sense
he would probably he would probably
he probably goes with heinz right so if
he had a hat it would say make america
hinds again right yeah probably but then
again like well i guess it's on it's on
america's dime so he's probably buying
the best stuff
hmm i i don't know i mean i would
imagine i mean the guy
the guy has no class whatsoever right so
it's not like and
you've heard the story from charlie
sheen right where he gave trump the
couplings at his wedding he trump took
off his cufflinks and gave him to him at
his wedding's like here here's a gift
like that was trump's gift that's right
pathetic number one
but charlie sheen had these cufflinks
looked at and they were fake right
they're [ __ ] fake they were ponies
and he's like you know and that's an old
story but i would imagine it's the same
he has no class even when it comes to
ketchup all right so i'm gonna here i
will pull the group right now because i
have two images made let's see the
people in the channel i will ask you
should it be make america catch up again
or make america hines again
so put your put your answer down in the
chat so gabe can
kind of take up are you going to put it
on the the twitter page are you going to
put it on the just just have them do it
in the chat just do it just do it on the
on the chat right now yeah
put your put your answer in the chat
there yeah and gable determine
um which which one uh goes i'm sure
they'll give you some other ideas too
yeah yeah and we can we can keep going
uh
i originally well the reason the
original
reason i went with heinz is because i
was like oh heinz 45. it's a joke i will
make in the next what was that
right
so i don't know
people are saying heinz i think
it sounds it sounds better behind okay
heinz it is and sounds better
let's just
we will give uh
okay all right i'm gonna i'm gonna post
it all right we can move on
so this this here it's speaking of heinz
ketchup um again
this is i and i know it seems trivial
and i know a lot of people like oh
you're you're you're you're losing sight
of the crimes like look america
obviously doesn't give a [ __ ] that this
guy is a criminal you have to prove that
he lost
and this picture is beautiful this
picture was going around
the entire internet and and people that
hear the story about the ketchup against
the wall will be able to see this image
and understand what it means
and i think it's very effective i know
it seems trivial but look these are the
things that live in the public spaces on
social media this is the this is the
[ __ ] that america cares about they want
to know what team kyrie irving is going
to play on they want to know if
tom brady is retired or not today these
are the things they worry about so you
got to do it in little snippets here and
this is the perfect little snippet right
the same i mean
if we if we were to just break down kind
of the stuff we've heard so far you know
there's 250 million dollar grift rudy
was drunk
rudy was
was ruining people's reputation and
lives trump was trying to strangle his
his secret service driver he was
throwing plates and full of ketchup
against the wall
like this place is an absolute [ __ ] show
man
well i mean speaking of [ __ ] show
you posted
we were live on air
and the after hearing and we noticed
that grandpa poopy pants himself was was
rage truthing or rage lying i don't know
what the [ __ ] you call it over there
it's a fraudulent social media site but
you posted uh this on our podcast
uh twitter page at tony michael's pod
um and you must have been one of the
first to it because it kind of everyone
spread it around yeah
and he this is his first statement about
cassidy hutchinson
and he's like in this in this very
statement
he says in the very i hardly know who
this person is cassie hutchinson and
then down at the very end of this huge
run-on sentence which doesn't make any
sense he says i personally turned her
request down so he personally knew who
she was so there was some sort of uh
connection here and then at the end he
says uh i didn't want her to go or be a
team a member of the team so he didn't
know who she was but he knew her enough
that he didn't want to go right and then
he says she's bad news which is you know
here's here's the other thing that i'll
say at the end of this where she he says
she's bad news the one reason why he
uses this is because cassie hutchinson
is not she's a very attractive person
she's a very attractive woman and
yesterday she had her hair down she had
the white uh uh coat on with the black
dress she she looked very clean very
buttoned up very polished she was ready
to give her testimony so he couldn't
knock her lips because that's a trump
thing he would not not only that but
like the professionalism that she kept
saying you know mr meadows or you know
uh uh mr jordan or whoever it might be
um
you know they made sure and she
especially is you know especially made
sure to you know her appearance was was
clean professional her um the way into
which he spoke was clean and
professional like if you're going to
remove all the ways in which you could
attack someone right whether it's on
appearance or the way they speak or just
their mannerisms like she was very
professional very postured like
everything was around her which to say
there's like there was there was no flaw
right you could only then go against her
on the actual story itself and the story
itself
had been verified she's a first
hand account witness of
this [ __ ] that went down right
well here is jessica denson we had her
on yesterday um jessica denson is the
trump nda killer she's the only person
out there that's been able to kill the
trump campaign's uh nda in court she did
it all by herself fighting the trump
allies and the trump team
but here she uh talks about the
statement that i just showed she said
this playbook of slandering honest women
as bad news
is as sick as it gets
i know it all too well just a few of the
slander tags i got from trump boys club
for doing nothing but my job quote
unquote out of control [ __ ]
quote [ __ ] quote what's her
malfunction leaker spy you know all the
typical trump playbook so jessica denson
even
even confirms that this language that he
puts in this statement is just absolute
[ __ ] and it's just because he's
scared of the truth right just like you
called her he called her a leaker what
does a leaker do they leak information
seems kind of convenient that it you
would leak
so she knows stuff and he knows her that
she knows see that's the craziest part
about the whole thing that he doesn't
know her is and that's why the select
committee set up the map of the white
house like that was the first thing
right right because they established
donald trump knows who this is and
wasn't in some basement right you know
this person was right there in the heat
of all the action that day and leading
up to that day she was there she was she
was at mark meadows side she knew
everything mark meadows did yeah i mean
they even went to the extent of her
telling the story where where like she's
talking to mark meadows
and he's looking down on this phone he's
not responding she's like hello hello
right mark mark hello are you gonna
respond
like you just and and uh lincoln project
actually has a great video it's an older
video and i sent it to you this morning
i'm like this is
yeah it
is it is very well done and it does go
to play to like all the moments in which
she was talking about being in the room
with mark meadows and mark meadows being
so focused on his phone and she was like
he never looked up he just kind of ex
you know lightly acknowledged and then i
had to get his attention and he goes oh
yeah yeah and even when even when she
said hey i just had an interesting
conversation with rudy giuliani outside
about january 2nd or like january 6th
today is january 2nd of 2021 and he goes
oh i have a feeling it's going to be a
very very bad day or like things get
very very bad on gender yeah rudy was
excited about it mark was not excited
yeah rudy oh god i i'm still i'm very
certain that rudy is one of the people
that has communicated with one of the
witnesses
to uh you me you mean at the very end of
the year at the very end yeah and where
where where uh liz cheney put up uh text
messages or emails i think yeah she set
up a text message and a phone call yeah
that's what it was and and she was
quoting from them and it's basically
witness tampering as well right yeah
yeah and i think it could be one of them
could be lead to that yeah yeah and i
guarantee you one of them and here's the
thing they already know
who it is they're just like hey right
and and now that person knows and now
that person and that's what they're
doing is they're warning that person hey
we know about this yeah yeah and i i i i
think your
assumption that it is rudy or your guess
that it's really is really pretty spot
on i mean it's probably pretty close
because we we listened to some of the
voicemails that rudy giuliani left brad
rathersburger in georgia like hey aren't
you a good republican a good republican
would call me back i'm calling you as a
republican i'm calling you as a friend
you know this this friend loyalty
mobster talk [ __ ]
so but lincoln project had this video
i'm not sure when they put this out it's
been a while but they put it they they
retweeted it here um as the
as the hearing was going this is why
mark meadows wasn't looking up from his
phone um so let's um
let's watch why he wasn't
obviously this is a screenshot
or a screen capture of what it would be
like if mark meadows
[Music]
it's got notification here from the
capitol police that there is a threat
inside you know i could watch the house
floor and i could see some of the floor
staff running you just don't see that
inside the house
there then jim jordan's calling him the
protesters have penetrated
uh the capital tear gas has been
deployed
[Music]
people is concerned but there is no
place for violence i've served in places
overseas in africa and afghanistan and
other where violence
is how we solve our disputes not here in
america we solve it through debate and
discussion
doing but we are moving downstairs into
the basement he rejects the call from
donald trump there which is yeah on
brand
and of course we see the technology
we know are real these text messages are
really good
[Applause]
spot on um even back then and now it's
kind of crazy that um yeah i think this
came out i mean obviously had to come
out after the text message were revealed
which right yeah which was the end of
last year yeah december timeframe so
probably at the beginning of the new
year or the very end of the uh
because i i remember i made the dramatic
reading at the very end
of uh
2021 like the week before
[Music]
the
before christmas pretty much like a few
days before christmas right right well
yeah because your very first one you
kind of had the fireplace in the
background you had christmas music
exactly it was it was like a christmas
kind of theme and then you had to change
it because there was more text messages
yeah yeah i was like oh there's
here's here's bret baer on fox news
it is really stunning when even fox news
is speechless watch the end of this
when he when he finishes his little uh
his tick tock of the facts that came out
from the hearing
watch at the end as they're like yep and
it's just their speech let's watch and i
think what you pointed to sandra was
the most compelling when she quotes mark
meadows saying uh pat you heard the
president he doesn't care
he thinks mike deserves it he doesn't
think they're doing anything wrong as
far as they're literally literally
calling for the vice president to be
hung and then pat cipolioni says this is
effing crazy according to hutchinson
this testimony was very compelling from
beginning to end she obviously had
access to all of the players we are now
hearing from the former president on
various posts where he questions her
uh
accuracy i love that he calls him post
he's like yeah host posts post like they
they've even been informed at fox news
not to call them truce not to call them
tweets call them post it's hilarious he
goes after her directly says he doesn't
know who she is and said he didn't lunge
at the secret service agent and the
beast uh and i want to get to the secret
service thing we'll get to that in the
tweet and the trendy trends here when we
get to that part because there's a lot
of fodder back and forth with that and i
want to give you some messaging to carry
with you out there but uh let's listen
to what brett bear the rest of what he
said that didn't happen he says he
didn't throw his lunch against the wall
that didn't happen and that she's lying
cassie hutchinson is under oath on
capitol hill um the president is on
truth social
right there he's like like he just
[ __ ] digs on him hard yeah like like
this gets right at the heart of what
this is like look cassidy hutchinson as
much as anyone might say hey you should
have done this sooner uh she is doing it
now i i don't know that she
i don't know if she's a hero here right
um
you know that's what i was telling
yesterday like i think all of these
people
no one in here are heroes none of these
people are heroes because what they did
was they waited and up until the point
at which they were served a subpoena and
asked to come in and give their
deposition
or testimony did they actually come
forward so imagine if nobody did
anything there was no january 6 there
was no liz cheney there was no one in
here to actually have a committee and
request someone's appearance or their
deposition in terms of giving something
under oath on on the facts
none of that would have happened which
means i guarantee
none of these people would have come
forward whether out of their own concern
for being known as the person who didn't
say anything or being the person who was
um
threatened by trump kind of goons
whatever it might be
none of these people actually gave any
sort of word before
january 6 came forward and said hey we
actually have evidence of this and this
and this you might want to speak up now
before later
so like yeah i'm happy and i'm grateful
that all of these people especially
cassidy have come forward and given
their testimony and given their
line item
account of what went down from january
2nd and beyond i mean even before that
but really january 2nd i think is when
she realized i should probably write
this stuff down and she did so
especially after her well right because
she she is a note taker like that's one
of the things that she does for meadows
and she's like well maybe i should start
taking notes on this stuff so that i
have this because i might need it right
and that was the other thing that i
noticed during her video testimony like
when they were showing her video
testimony she had this binder and it
wasn't like just like a notebook that
she'd written i mean like it was
organized and she was stepping through
it it had tabs she knew it was a lot it
was it was numbered that was that is the
thing that matters here it was not like
you know especially in a court document
like oh go to page 47 line 15. so i want
to know exactly which item that way
because you want you're in your court
you want to make sure that you're at as
efficient as possible but you're as
specific as possible and this is exactly
what was there was going through and i'm
you know i'm gonna i'm gonna safely
assume she went through with the lawyers
to say like okay here's everything and
they're like all right categorize it by
this and this and this so on page 47
line 15 or page 56 line 12 or whatever
might be you know exactly where to go
back to to say mark meadow said this he
mark meadows crossed out this line in
this statement mark meadows did this
trump said this trump threw ketchup
and plates against the wall right the
mag
exactly the mags down who cares they're
not going to use the weapons on me i'm
not scared they're not there to use
right just all this stuff but but i get
it gets at the heart of that cassie
hutchinson
you know some may consider her hero some
may not the most important thing that
she did was her duty and betty thompson
said that at the end she did her duty
as as a former
um
aide to the chief of staff because we
have to remember that she is in an
office of of the united states she was
serving us
as an aide to the office of chief of
staff she wasn't just mark meadows chief
of staff she was our aide to our chief
of staff that's the most important thing
to remember here um and she did her duty
by going yesterday and giving
her testimony under oath that the best
of her knowledge that she could say that
yes this is what i remember this is what
i believe let's listen though to the end
here where they're absolutely speechless
uh making his statements what was so
compelling i think
is is how it was laid out we always
point out that there's not a push back
and it would have been great to hear jim
jordan or some congressman say some
other angle to this but the testimony in
and of itself is really really powerful
[Laughter]
can you still hear it
just absolutely speechless they can't
even i mean like yeah
when i originally watched this clip i
was like oh the clip's over and then
they're like oh sandra and i was like oh
[ __ ] they're still on right it's just
they're just like everyone did not move
in that moment and i was like oh okay
yeah this is crazy but the other thing
too is like even jim jordan remember jim
jordan is the guy who was like uh i i i
i i where
when asked about hey did you talk to
trump on january 6 how many times did he
actually talk to trump and he was like
uh well um well it all
it um you know it and it's like oh we
know exactly why we know exactly why he
wanted to be on the committee he wanted
a heads up because there would have been
a conflict of interest he was someone
that is under investigation he is
someone that is of interest to them
where they were like oh yeah we've got
mark meadows on the phone and cassidy
hutchinson then goes out and says that
yesterday which like oh we had heard
uh jim jordan being somewhat involved
and now we know he was directly calling
trump
to get a hold of him and tell him you
know one way or the other in terms of
how to handle the situation but then now
later he was like well i
and then you know meanwhile he's talking
about inflation or gas prices or
something [ __ ] [ __ ] like that
while he's looking for pardons yeah he's
like oh okay look look like you know all
of these people are freaking out like
as soon as she came up there i think
some of them might have thought the
possibility in in remembering like oh
who did i speak to on that day okay here
are all the like the data points of
people that could connect me to trying
to communicate with trump or having some
involvement on january 6th or before
that
but now
he's like oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] and like i feel like for him
you know they had that one tweet they're
like oh that's their witness okay cool
or whatever it was some dumb tweet which
is like you guys are [ __ ] yourselves
right now right
now and the reason why is because it
seems at first that cassidy hutchinson
would be insignificant but yesterday she
proved her significance because she is
basically mark meadows
eyes and ears she saw everything he saw
she heard everything he heard and she
even she even was the gatekeeper to mark
meadows in some of these instances you
watched as she gave testimony about what
the president how furious he was and she
had to go to meadows and tell him and it
was just back and forth and she
sometimes was in between the president
his staff and her boss who is the chief
of staff like right
i mean they asked her at the very
beginning when they laid out the plans
of where her office was and where she
was in terms of meadows and trump they
said how much time during the day
normally did you spend with meadows and
she was like well
there was very little time that we were
not either together or not communication
right when they were probably taking the
[ __ ] when they were taking this [ __ ] he
was like i want you to take notes on how
long this take we gotta you know i would
imagine i would imagine that cassie
hutchinson
probably had to eat her lunch
while she was listening to these
buffoons like she probably had to eat
her lunch on the go and she was trying
to [ __ ] take notes and and work for
these buffoons
hey sit sit in the corner over here and
eat the lunch like that's how much they
did not respect her and respect her at
the same time where they're like oh well
you can be involved but from afar but
still having within he said that having
said that in that first statement he
talks that trump talks about bringing
her down to mar-a-lago and how she
wanted to come to mar-a-lago i wonder
why trump wanted the person who was
standing next to mark meadows the entire
time at his staff in mar-a-lago so he
could keep an eye on her
this is all i i mean to act like cassie
hutchison wanted to go to mar-a-lago
maybe she did maybe she didn't i'm sure
she wanted a job i'm sure she wanted
paid to do a job that she is highly
trained to do
um but i would imagine the reason why
trump and any of her the team decided
that she might be a good candidate to go
down so donald trump could keep an eye
on her is because of what happened
yesterday and not only that but it's a
fact of like again
i know i don't even know who she is
never heard of her don't know don't know
what she's talking about but you're also
the person that she was the special
assistant to
[Music]
donald trump right like your special
assistant after being the former aide of
the chief of staff of your white house
mark meadows has no idea who she is no
idea not not at all never seen her what
does that say either that tells you that
he's [ __ ] lying which is the truth
he's [ __ ] lying or he's derelict in
his duty that he [ __ ] hires people he
doesn't know who they are or a third one
his mental cognitive abilities have just
degraded down to a fact where he's not
that that stable genius he's not that
guy who aced that the mocha
it's almost like his his skull is full
of ketchup or something right but it's
the same it's the same approach marger
taylor green i do not recall i don't
remember it's like for a representative
maybe you shouldn't be in office
speaking speaking of not recalling this
footage here is something we really
didn't talk about during the commentary
yesterday
but holy actual [ __ ] is it scary as hell
that mike flynn
was the national security adviser and
really he was put on a list to be vice
president of the united states
and the question that really gets me
because liz cheney is uh is asking him
questions and the testimony here for the
deposition of the january 6 committee
this clip they played during the hearing
but mike flynn the act the last question
that she asked him about the peaceful
transfer power listen to this [ __ ]
traitor take the fifth on what should be
easy questions and we'll talk about it
on the other side do you believe the
violence on january 6 was justified
morally
what you believe the violence on january
6 was justified legally
what
general flynn do you believe in the
peaceful transition of power in the
united states of america
this is it
wow holy [ __ ]
okay so he takes the fifth on the first
question
which is the the morality question yeah
right and he's like fifth like what so
okay so let's explain to folks out there
which i know our audience knows what the
fifth is
it's you have the right to take the the
fifth amendment you do not you cannot
you don't have to self-incriminate
and you would usually use the fifth in a
question
where
if the answer that you give
would possibly
maybe
have
a self-incriminating factor like it
could prove that you committed crimes by
even saying it out loud
which means that either mike flynn is
just a [ __ ] [ __ ] box here and he's
taking the fifth every question just to
[ __ ] with them
no the i'm gonna own the libtards which
liz janey is not a liberal yeah that's
one thing i want to point out here with
this video that she was actually
questioning him which is beautiful
by the way
um but
either that or there is proof somewhere
and he knows it
that is contrary to the question that
she asked a simple question is this her
morality yeah and then the final one the
thing the one that really puts
uh the cherry on top of the treason
sunday here
is the one where she's like do you
believe in a peaceful transfer of power
and he's like fifth
what that like
how in the [ __ ]
how in the [ __ ] i mean literally it's a
yes or no question i'm gonna replay it
here watch this this last question here
because that's the most important one
here
here's the last one
general flynn do you believe in the
peaceful transition of power in the
united states of america it's a yes or
no question gabe yeah it's pretty it's
not it's i mean he could elaborate right
like if he gave an answer yes but or no
but our yes and
no and
yes because no because
but it literally is a yes or no question
and liz janey knows this and they know
he's gonna take the fifth this is so
dumb for mike flynn to do this because
this is the record that we have of this
[ __ ] guy in his career like this is
it
this is it and this is a guy who
received a pardon from trump and
probably was seeking more pardons
as after january 6 and that's why he
can't
say this [ __ ] out loud because even a
yes or no
could incriminate him to this question
and let's hear his answer again
the fifth
holy [ __ ] that yeah it's just a fifth
that piece of tape right there
is absolutely bone chilling that that
[ __ ] was our hour hour
hours our government our national
security advisor he was the guy standing
in the way
of making sure our country was safe and
the president whoever the president was
that held that office
was briefed on what the state of our
national security was and this guy
can't even can't even answer yes or no
to the question whether he believes in a
peaceful transfer of power or he'll
incriminate himself holy actual [ __ ]
that is absolutely batshit crazy now of
course
most people in america don't know who
mike flynn is most people do not know
who liz genius they just don't [ __ ]
know they don't know who mark meadows is
they don't know who cassie hutches most
of them don't even know that mike pence
was a vice president yeah be quite
honest with you so they're not going to
member remember this clip that is very
significant in in
in the whole [ __ ] story
of the trump president in and of itself
yeah that he had this guy's a national
security adviser and this guy was he was
considering making the vice president
imagine if he would have been the vice
president holy we would have been
[ __ ] screwed
this guy doesn't even believe in the
peaceful transfer of power
and he was going to be the vice
president the guy who's supposed to read
the envelope as mike pence eventually
did
but that's why the ketchup story is so
important right because no one's going
to know this anyone who sees this video
they're not going to list genius hang on
mike flynn they have no idea they don't
even know what the national security
advisor does i have no idea it's
it's one of those moments where you know
again
it's the reason why you'll remember
drunk rudy right these are things that
you know as the as good you know
great production
value from the producer to figure out
like yeah this is all [ __ ] crazy like
this is
you know ketchup on the walls like the
[ __ ] hitting the fan type of stuff where
you're like oh my god
normally you would say
that's that's unlikely i would never
believe that but after four years
of seeing trump in office you're like
well that's
that sounds about right you know it like
the math checks out right
so it's like at the end of the day when
people are like oh yeah ketchup on the
wall
because it's insane to be like a grown
man who's an adult who's in his 70s he's
the sitting president of the united
states it's eating ketchup
and ketchup well i mean i i hate ketchup
i in the audience go ahead say all kinds
of mean things about me i can't stand
ketchup catch up bad
i mean what are you five with the
ketchup i mean maybe on fries maybe i'll
give you a pass i mean i would say a
five-year-old kind of meal is you're
cutting up the hot dog you know for the
child in the little bowl maybe that's
what it was maybe see i was trying to
figure out why why why we didn't hear
about what was what was being dipped in
the ketchup because we really didn't
hear that i want to know that part of
the story really honestly what was he
eating that he was dipping in the
ketchup or putting ketchup on because my
view of it is that donald trump probably
doesn't put ketchup on the same plate as
his food yeah yeah he's you know no no
it's all compared to him you know he
doesn't do it i mean you know like any
other president or person who lives
there the food is prepared for you but
it's probably the thing that you know
would be interesting to know is like the
specific requests that are made for his
meal right it's a diet coke
fried food kfc
or mcdonald's but then he's like i feel
like a hot dog and they're like sir you
could choke on that it's a choking
hazard like you don't chew well and he's
like my wand my hot dog and they're like
okay diet coke damn it okay you know
what
did you just get him a hot dog get him
hop cut it up in tiny little pieces bite
size
so then they're you know they they give
them a hot dog that's cut up into tiny
little pieces and then they're like oh
do it without the skin because that's
even more of a problem so he's got this
skinless hot dog that's cut up into
pieces and he's dipping it into ketchup
and then you know he has his tantrum
because he's like i want to go to the
capitol and this isn't going the way
that i want and he's throwing dishes
like he's having a [ __ ] tantrum and
he's a five-year-old i mean i'll call
now it's toddler trump that's what he is
it's tyler trump trump having a tantrum
on january 6 and that's what people will
remember that's what americans can
remember you will never be able to
forget that like where were you when you
learned that trump was throwing dishes
and ketchup against the wall and trying
to choke the secret service uh driver
who was in the beast and i know people i
see people in the chat who were talking
earlier they were saying
it's not the beast it was an suv it is
the beast
look at the testimony of what they were
talking about he followed angle into the
car
that is the beast
it says under it says
uh trump got into the presidential limo
known as the beast with secret service
special agent bobby angle the head of
the protective detail so once the
president got into the vehicle with
bobby
he thought they were going back to the
capitol and when bobby relayed to him no
we don't have the assets to do it that's
when he had his tantrum and didn't try
to take over the wheel and choke him out
so i just want a quick correction for
people in the chat who's saying it's an
suv it's not the beast it's literally on
record as the beast
right well and a lot of people were
debating the um
the secret service story and
peter alexander disputed the well he had
sources that disputed the secret service
secret service agents now they're saying
oh well he was irate in the vehicle
but he didn't uh actually try to
look if these people if these people
want to come forward here's the thing i
highly doubt
that
that liz cheney and benny thompson and
the rest of the committee would not be
able
to
verify some of these details
so
i have very
you know very hard to believe that they
wouldn't go forward with this if they
didn't say oh yeah you know what
it actually is there is truth to this
and we have verified to various sources
now that could be either through
presidential detail with other people
speaking but you've got one anonymous
account that says on behalf of secret
service
that it wasn't actually how it went down
and unfortunately i feel like there's a
lot of reporters who are getting
kind of
doing the run around and getting played
yeah so by the way i mean
i actually have a secret video from
inside the the beast
um i have some footage from inside the
beast oh yeah it's not a very long video
but it kind of shows it kind of shows
what happened here's um here's what
seems to be donald trump it's definitely
not john walsh dressed up as donald
trump it definitely seems to be donald
trump here but here's some
here's some um some secret footage from
inside the quote unquote the beast of
the quote-unquote right the beast which
is again what was said during the sworn
in under oat testimony from cassidy
hutchinson of her
recount of what happened that day
let's let's watch the secret footage
that we have obtained
from what is not john walsh dressed up
as donald trump
that was an amazing rally now let's go
to the capitol sure that would be
dangerous we're gonna head back to the
west wing i'm the effing president take
me to the capitol now nope this car's
going back to the white house oh no i
want to go to the capitol donald you
know better we talked about this
with everyone else i said no coups today
young man no butts i want to keep being
the president sir sir get your hands off
the steering wheel that's it no big mac
for you
can i still get the happy meal
so there there you have it there you
have it definitely not john walls
definitely not definitely not john walls
dressed up as donald trump for sure
that is that is um
verified quote unquote verified
uh footage from inside the suv for sure
um thank you john walsh for giving us
that great piece of of content um
but in all seriousness this reporting
that the the secret service want to
testify i i would love to hear the
secret service testify under oath yeah
that would be fantastic if they if they
want to come forward like if the if
peter alexander and the other people who
who believe this one anonymous source of
a secret service agent that says this is
actually not what happened if they want
to come forward and give their testimony
they're more than welcome just like
donald trump who is requested equal to
oh actually not requested he has
demanded equal time via truth social
because it's all great he used the word
demand he said i demand equal time so if
he wants to have equal time there is a
chair and a microphone and a lot of
cameras which we have
our dedicated camera for
if he wants to come if he wants to come
speak he could totally go do that yeah
absolutely well i i i think
that if these people actually start to
um to bone up to testify whether it's
secret service or any other person
that's refuting some of these claims
which they won't they won't do that uh
you notice that the people who could
actually refute some of this stuff have
refused to testify some have even been
held in contempt of congress because of
it
you see we have some super chats coming
in thank you everyone for the
for the super chats um
but
look
the thing is about the secret service
and then testifying i'm all for it i
would love to hear not just from the
secret service but from john eastman i
think he could testify publicly i think
i think we could get we could get
jeffrey clark to testify publicly i
think i think maybe just maybe rudy
giuliani could sit in the hot seat and
let liz cheney
go at his ass for maybe an hour or two
right and i'm sure the january 6 select
committee
would make room hearing after hearing
after hearing for these people to come
testify in public i really do think they
would do that they're not scared because
here's the thing is the select committee
knows the truth and the people who the
truth is gonna be told on and dumped on
they know that the select committee
knows the truth and they know it after
liz cheney has been putting putting
these people on check like scott perry
these members who were who were seeking
pardons these members who were seeking
pardons know
that they were seeking pardons and they
know that january 6 select committee's
on to them just like martin luther green
is freaking out right he's freaking i
mean they they have done a very good job
of
of teasing
and not getting this stuff like you know
these are details that obviously is you
know an amazing job of nobody leaking
this stuff right nobody leaking the
stuff before the testimony or before the
hearings you know to show everyone the
car that's why you know
it's why they didn't send over uh all of
their evidence or at least partial of
their evidence to the doj because
they're like no we're not doing that if
you want to come see it you can come to
a specific uh secure room we'll have a
faraday cage you can't have any sort of
communication we'll collect your devices
and you can come in here and you can and
it's obvious that they have right yeah
exactly they're like oh [ __ ] it's the
same reason why certain directors will
say i only have one copy of a script and
i will let these lead actors or
actresses come in and read it because we
don't want it to leak and ruin the story
and you'll sign a big maybe like a
marvel yeah like a lot of christian uh
christopher nolan films they're like
here's one script come into the secure
room we'll take your phone we'll take
any devices you go in there spend as
long as much time as you want to read
through the script you have any
questions i'm right outside
and also sign this nda it's the same
reason that they did that for the doj
they didn't want this stuff getting out
there so when it did come out it was a
huge [ __ ] splash it was ketchup on
the wall it was drunk rudy it was this
or it was that right it was you better
get a good effing defense attorney right
these are all moments where you're like
wow these are quotes
where
we realize we realize i mean we knew
this we knew this from evidence that
we've seen in public right it's never
been testified under oath in an official
committee hearing about the weapons
where he's like just take down the mags
who cares you're not going to use them
on me but which is significant because
here's sean hannity and you you posted
this video too with some laugh faces
because it's hilarious what it is the
only way to react to it it's insane
[ __ ]
listen to the words that sean hannity
uses about firearms it's very important
the word that he uses because it's all
of a sudden changed sean and he's
changed his tune from there were no
weapons there were no firearms to listen
to how he his language now the so-called
witness also claimed president trump
wanted to get rid of the metal detectors
at the january 6 rally and allow armed
individuals to attend today president
trump flat out denied this claim oh okay
i guess we'll take his word for it right
exactly we'll take his word for what he
says
on on his post on live
live social let's let's listen but
listen really carefully how how handed
he describes
the firearms and pointed out a simple
fact
zero guns were ever discharged by those
that breached the capitol or in dc that
day
that same argument is what they used
earlier when they're like well i mean is
it illegal if we never actually
successfully pulled off the coup right
right is it in a is it a coup attempt if
we didn't actually pull if we didn't
succeed in the church
if we didn't actually hang mike pence
right now right now
like look
the fact that even that argument is out
there which is like yeah doesn't it
it doesn't even acknowledge the whole
like there weren't guns there it was
guns weren't discharged
by by well and what they're doing here
is they're doing two different things
they're saying they're they're trying to
build their gut the gun argument that
because they've been saying that there
were no weapons prove it i think
marjorie taylor green even even tweeted
prove that there's rep they did prove it
they they proved it yesterday with the
[ __ ] radio transmissions of the
police who were observing these people
with firearms
yeah right they're they're doing their
job to identify the people who have
weapons and and this is this is going
back to the whole oh well there are
there were there were undercover of
course there were undercover officers
because they were looking for people who
had weapons and they were placing an
undercover officer close to those people
to keep track of them of where they were
going and what they were doing with
those weapons right that was the whole
point that was the whole point yeah but
here but here you have sean hannity not
only you know spewing the dis that that
that the trump supporters didn't
discharge a firearm because the fact is
is that there were firearms discharged
that day and ashley babbitt was shot
because she breached a secure area and
she was told not to breach that secure
area and and trump even tweeted about it
well or whatever the posted it's hard to
know exactly what you call that thing
but let's listen to what sean hannity
does on the follow-up here according to
so many so-called journalists in the
media mob it was hyperventilating again
oh we we got him
again this time trump brusher collusion
oh we got him let's impeach him anyway
they said they did impeach him by the
way yeah twice
right they didn't beat him twice he's
been impeached by sean hannity you
[ __ ] when people say they're like oh
he wasn't ever impeached he's like okay
yeah you want a full impeachment like he
was removed it requires both the senate
in the house however he wasn't removed
yeah but he was impeached though just
like bill clinton was impeached yeah
um you know yeah it's yeah well you know
look there's
uh again
cassie cassidy hutchinson may not be a
hero but it looks like
from your place look at here um gabe's
is definitely picking up one great
choice did you see this on time or
something i i got a i got a screenshot
yeah look at this deleted time oh they
deleted it time magazine
says
cassidy hutchinson this person of the
year it says mystery witness here
um i don't know it looks legit to me i
don't know so it looks like it's coming
july it said it the looks like it's
coming out july 4th so july 4th huh
which
i would say that's the next episode the
next the next issue yeah special issue
july 4th yeah well hmm
might want to go ask time why they took
this down
uh someone page daniel dale and see if
he can um yeah somebody tagged daniel
dale and uh
i i'm sure daniel dale would like to
question gabe's post here he always
likes to track down things that don't
matter so go go tag
[Laughter]
go tag but the other thing i like about
the sean hannity segment is that he
doesn't of course ever address
any of the text messages that uh that he
sent mark meadows right the same reason
why laura ingraham didn't address any of
the messages the same reason why they
were like oh [ __ ] they're ruining the
blm antifa message that we've got going
he needs to stop this or he'll ruin the
legacy our legacy right and so you're
you're
you see that he's texting these people
on the day of january 6 and say hey look
you need to do something right now or
else it's all [ __ ] ruined and all
this stuff that we had built up over the
last four years to show how fox is right
and white is right will go down the
[ __ ] [ __ ] and the ketchup against
the wall like these are all moments that
they're like
you know very much trying to secure
their position
but don't want to address it obviously
it's the same you know again same reason
why fox news wasn't willing to show the
first night of the hearings you know for
that awkward moment where that message
between uh sean hannity and kaylee
mackin and he comes on the screen
talking about the 25th amendment and he
needs to shut this [ __ ] down
you know so you see it all the time and
you know he'll be like oh no there were
no guns like change the narrative let's
talk about the guns but we will not
address the fact that i was literally
shown another text message today
about my involvement with trying to
communicate with mark meadows
on january 6th
uh gabe we have some breaking news here
this is a statement from justice breyer
to the president united states um
telling him that he is informing him of
his intent to retire so it is now
official uh from justice breyer here to
the president united states and we know
that uh katangi brown jackson has been
confirmed to replace
uh justice breyer but we have not
received the formal
um intent to retire and here it is this
is the formal intent to retire from the
supreme court of the united states from
justice stephen breyer so you will i'm
sure june 30th was his official day
right he he didn't like
expedite yeah um
he talks about it says you have
nominated the united s as uh you you and
the united states uh senate has
confirmed the honorable contangi brown
jackson to secede me uh in the office
and i understand that she's prepared to
take the prescribed oaths to begin her
service
as the 116th member of this court so it
looks like it's going to be
pretty much immediately because they are
going to recess and just just to give
you the first the letter it says this
past january i wrote to inform you of my
intent to retire from regular active
service as an associate justice of the
supreme court of the united states upon
court
rising from its summer recess
yeah and and he goes on to say in the
bottom
um well it's oh right yeah the original
the original letter said uh late june
early july
so this is right on right on
and also like probably after the last
week he's like i need to get the [ __ ]
out of here man
right
he's [ __ ] bananas right right he
wants to probably detach from it
according accordingly my retirement from
active service
under provisions
uh for the legal code will be
uh effective on thursday june 30th
2022 so tomorrow yeah he's out today and
she's in tomorrow so they'll probably
swear her in um either late today or
tomorrow morning i'm sure
um as the new associate justice that
will replace stephen breyer he also said
it's been my great honor to participate
as a judge in the effort to maintain our
constitution and rule of law um notice
his his uh choice of words here it has
been my great honor to participate as a
judge
in the effort
to maintain our constitution and rule of
allah
it doesn't seem as if justice breyer
believes
that it has been
um a successful effort but an effort to
maintain so right with some of the
decisions that have been made have well
let's go to the tweety tweets and the
trendy trends here to um really see what
some of these decisions
have you've been keeping close eye on
what some of these decisions were today
yeah there was one there was one that
was about uh
tribal lands federal lands and crimes
that are committed what was that case
what was that case called i noticed as i
was uh
uh huertas uh yeah do you are you aware
of the
what the decision was and so the
decision it was a 5-4 decision and
actually gorsuch sided with the more
liberal progressive side
um because he had just had one prior
that he
uh oh and i see if i can find that uh
i've got it i've got a tweet
yeah
yeah if you want to send that to me yeah
then we can bring it up um so it has to
do with tribal lands right
it kind of dumps on um
natives
and
from what i understand i did i didn't
get a chance to read the decision this
morning yeah i mean so it's uh it
yeah i just sent you a link for it um
yeah castro huerta it's oklahoma versus
castro who is a 5'4 neil gorsuch writes
dissent joined by briar sotomayor and
kagan
okay so this is from uh scotus blog
it reads the supreme court rules
that the states can
prosecute crimes against native american
victims committed on native american
reservations if the defendant is
non-native
um so what what does this mean what what
i i don't know of this case i'm not sure
what's going on so it comes back to um
and there's been a lot you know there's
more expert opinions because i'm not a
lawyer but there was the the the mcgirt
versus oklahoma which i believe gorsuch
did actually uh this is from 2020 ruled
on in terms of who could actually come
back and and prosecute
right and how it was handled because
this is the difference between saying
there's federal land and there's state
land right and the state doesn't have
jurisdiction so like if you're in
oklahoma and you're on a native american
reservation right on that piece of
federal land which is granted to the
natives for that reservation then the
state of oklahoma doesn't have the right
to prosecute yeah but they're saying in
this case that they do have the right to
prosecute as long as the defendant is
non-native yeah
so so in other words if a non-native
person goes on to native land
commits a crime
then they um
then they can
then the state that that yeah
both the federal government and oklahoma
the state itself can prosecute crimes
committed by non-indians against indians
in indian country rich which is taking
jurisdiction away from the natives right
so it's like
yeah so justice is more this is more of
the states have the right or they don't
you know again it's um
more of this where do the states have
the rights and doesn't have the rights
and conservatives republicans the nazis
in this country really are are getting
it all
are muddying the waters here right and
the decision it ended up rolling back
the supreme court's landmark ruling in
mcgirt versus oklahoma which is from
2020 and while rbg
voted in favor of tribal sovereignty amy
coney barrett now votes against it and
her vote makes a difference which brings
it you know between the 5'4 gorsuch
dissents and says
where our predecessors refuse to
participate in one state's unlawful
power grab at the expense of the
cherokee today's court
uh seeds to anothers
uh i mean this is a it's a brutal blow
against tribal sovereignty facilitated
entirely by the swap of rpg for barrett
so again like people don't think do you
think though do you think though that
this could be uh preempting
um you know their decision preempting
because some people have talked about
the federal government setting up um
safe havens for abortion
services and abortion clinics yep and
somebody's i i very much agree because
they were like oh you know because i
think that was a question was brought up
is like well what if we put clinics on
federal land right are we right they
allow what they would do is they would
allow clinics to open on federal land
which would be quote unquote neutral it
would be out of the jurisdiction of the
state exactly so now this kind of
may muddy that water exactly and so i
think originally you had uh biden and
harris this past week say something
along the lines of like that's something
that's not really on our radar right now
so now you've got this case now whether
they had insight into being like oh well
even if we did do that we would still
get [ __ ] over because we've got this
case that now creates precedent to say
that
uh non-uh non-indigenous non-native
people within a native within the native
country
uh
can prosecute right because under
federal law you know the
before it was exclusive right it was
separated and now it's saying well
actually you can
um
uh you can as the federal government and
oklahoma can prosecute committed so it's
no longer just states that can do it
right it's the federal government and
the state
um well i mean they definitely want to
be have a fascist state so they
definitely want to over
overextend their jurisdiction like this
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] here ken paxton
everyone knows is the texas attorney
general speaking of roe v wade and the
state and how they want to prosecute
because we can't forget about this roe v
wade decision and what it means
in these states where now women are
second-class citizens like not only that
but you've also got to think about the
people who are not just women right i
see people on tick tock being like guys
it's just roe v wade it's just abortion
right and these are also people who are
within the lgbtq community who are on
the republican side saying like guys
it's just abortion if you read page 31
of line whatever and it's like no you
guys missed the whole [ __ ] point once
this happens and once it did happen you
have now opened the floodgates it is
pandora's box because they're going to
use that as precedent to say states can
determine what and what cannot be done
in terms of rights that are given to
women rights that are given to people in
the lgbtq community you know rights
obviously that are taken away from women
to choose what they can do with their
own bodies
so it's a slippery slope where they say
well now that this is a this has been
established precedent we can now go with
this and then reference this and then do
this and reference these two and do this
and reference these three until a point
where you know no one has any rights
anymore and it's down to the state level
and you've got states saying you can do
this and other states you can do this
and no longer are people protected on a
federal level like they were just days
or weeks prior
well and it also extends to corporations
right and what they're going to do
because we we
we've
several corporations several companies
out there have announced that they will
make sure that the benefits that they
provide to their employees they will
give them assistance and travel
to get those
those benefits inside their health
packages because this is health care
that we're talking about right um and
ken paxton here the attorney general of
texas says no he will not he he's even
going to uh
he's this fascist is going to prosecute
private companies private corporations
for for uh making sure that their
employees get health benefits and health
care in states where it's legal listen
uh is that something that texas is going
to go after
you know we're going to look at it it's
actually you know new concept for us
these corporations deciding to pay for
people to go get their abortions we're
going to be looking at whether the
language covers at least the civil
number one this [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
that the services that that texas is
are are
outlawing abortions
most of them most of the procedures
aren't even an abortion most the time
it's a medical procedure to save a
woman's life or i don't know actual
contraception they're they're sliding
down this road so
i mean when you when you talk about
he's going to prosecute a company that's
going to provide assistance for a woman
to go to another state to have an iud
um
you know that medical device put in her
so she has contraception they're gonna
prosecute them because they provide
those benefits to their employees this
is really [ __ ] fascist [ __ ] this is
where i'm telling you they're not gonna
stop at women they're not gonna stop at
women i mean yes this is a direct front
to a woman's bodily autonomy
but they're not going to stop there i
mean that is it is a complete it
it's naive to think that somebody who
has this much power will say nah this is
enough guys i you know what i've got
enough power i've done enough ruling it
is naive and i think it's a little
foolish to think that anyone would say
yeah this is this is enough power it's
like a billionaire who says yeah this is
enough money that never happens right
people want to make more and more money
they want more and more control it's
over privacy medical
personal whatever it might be they are
going to take as much as they can and
try to rule over you and determine what
you can and can't do with anything the
funny thing about this
is you've got you know the attorney
general who's also under investigation
by the fbi for the last six or seven
years he just won his primary texas is
asked backwards by the way now
what i think is funny about this is you
as much as you know you like or don't
like elon musk
he is paying for people to get medical
procedures right
which although is it a private matter to
be like hey
look you know
uh tesla i've got this private matter i
need to go deal with and they're like
well what is it and they're like well
i'm getting abortion
it's like oh that's already personal
enough in private but you reveal that to
them and they say okay fine we will pay
for you to go to another state get this
procedure john so you can come back
because obviously for them they're like
well as long as this person doesn't
leave it you know improves the the the
cost of labor for us right there's all
these other incentives
and kind of motives they have behind the
scenes not just i'm being a good person
it's like how do i make sure this
benefits me as a company but gabe don't
you don't you see though that that
because elon wants to move to texas so
he knows
he already has he already has his stuff
down right so he's moving and the reason
why is because he's trying to keep his
employees his good employees right so so
so he's so here
um all you uh elon stands out there all
you elon sims out there the republicans
are now after elon musk i don't know if
you know this
what a what a convenient uh inconvenient
time really right in convenient time it
is the inconvenient truth that elon musk
is paying
to uh he's paying and covering these
procedures for women right whether out
of the goodness of his heart or the
goodness of his greed right either way
his company is paying for these
procedures of his greed i like that yeah
either way he's paying for these
procedures to be done on the company
dime
as a texas company
and you've got texas attorney general
ken paxton over here
who says i'm gonna go after companies on
the private level besides he's like you
know despite the fact that it's like oh
private corporations and capitalism they
can do what they want we don't want the
government overreaching and now he's
like i'm gonna come after these private
companies who are capitalists in this
country
for deciding what they do and don't do
with their own money and their own
employees sounds anti-free market to me
sounds like a big
big flopping
[Music]
just hypocrisy well let's listen to what
else this [ __ ] box says
and that's obviously what we can deal
with and so you know these these
penalties could even be for corporations
uh
over a hundred thousand dollars per
violation so we'll see we're looking at
that literally as we as we speak
what a piece of [ __ ] dude what a [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ]
oh that [ __ ] guy because we can't
forget about this ruby wade and i i also
want to point out to people that this
ruby weight thing is part of the coup
and it's trump's court that decided this
yeah yeah this was part of the this is
all part of the plan this is all part of
the coup they're still trying to get
decisions made to to undermine our
democracy and take our democracy away
from us the situation at hand here is
very important that you pay attention
that the roe v wade decision is part of
the coup it's it's a way to undermine
your freedoms your rights your democracy
to take it away from you because again
if you believe that we are not in a
democracy
when it is taken away from you you will
not believe that you lost anything
you will not believe that which i mean
if there was ever a moment where
like a lot of people were moving to
texas because it was like oh texas you
know free market and you know anti this
and anti that and you know we're gonna
we're gonna you know obviously
again texas ass backwards you've got a
private grid you've got a guy who wants
to give more rights to people with guns
after you've already seen
a a uh a horrific
tragedy happened ken paxton's like well
you know it's the will of god and it is
what it is right this is that same guy
the same guy that's under federal
indictment investigation for
for uh for for what he's done and so
this
this state itself is you know is
completely backwards
and
trying to trying to find a way to
to justify any of this stuff
is
inconceivable well you know the good
news is we still live in a democracy and
people still have the choice to vote
in a way that will give us those choices
back and we can work back to this
position
one case is you you you posted here and
andrew giuliani lost his primary
that's it that's the joke
because he did
i mean look at the area
of the map right okay so he is the color
let me take the banner down here yeah
yeah look at that there so andrew
giuliani is the color orange on this map
okay and at this point you know we're 76
percent this was at 8 43 p.m
and
the only area that's orange is down
down down down down down in the corner
right
he
somehow i don't know what the actual end
result was i haven't looked it up today
but you know again this is
very clear who the winner is 70 75 76
percent he's got 97 000 votes which is
23 percent
uh and i'll actually look up what the
updated kind of tally was but am i like
that's the to give you perspective of
how much people actually want to andrew
giuliani or respect the guy whether the
pat on the back that his dad got made
him look weak
or whatever it was but people either
before that moment
or just in general said rudy giuliani's
a hack he's a melting ghoul and he's a
drunk terrible person trying to ruin
people's lives innocent people lives as
we've seen through the january 6th
committee a lot of people like ah [ __ ]
this thing i don't want this guy
anywhere near
running this state because if if his
son's involved he
100
will have his finger
on legislation or or any sort of rule or
any sort of uh influence that uh
that andrew has as the governor or
potential governor because of the
primary but don't you think it goes at
the heart of uh how much
trump the people have lost respect for
trump and anyone around trump i mean
it's really it really is the the um
the story of rudy
rudy kaluti here where you know rudy
giuliani was always kind of known in new
york as a joke but i mean he was still
quote unquote america's mayor which is
long gone
long gone in the hearts of america and
the hearts of people in new york and new
york city um he's just a [ __ ] scumbag
and he can't stop being a scumbag
and the fact is that when him and his
son andrew giuliani which he looks like
the worst part that was left over from
the in vitro tube of eric trump
some people say that andrew giuliani is
actually the uh forgotten son of donald
trump it may be i mean i mean he looks
kind of similar to eric i'm just saying
you know they they do look like they are
split from the same chromosome maybe i
don't know but the point the point is
this is that in this country we have um
a situation where in new york at least
rudy giuliani is known as a joke where
he wasn't always known as a joke um but
in other parts of the country we have
republicans that are still winning you
you you notice that uh this mary miller
this is the [ __ ] can you find me in
the video of the late maybe a video of
her saying
uh the the hitler thing and then the
white life thing
you can find those mary miller she won
the primary
uh or it looks like she's going to win
the primary
in illinois uh here's the tweet from
david washerman um
in illinois 15 trump's endorse
endorsement seems to be making a big
difference
for rep
mary miller in counties neither she nor
rep rodney davis currently
she's in control of this primary now
which dave uh boy if he's saying it you
should probably
you should probably listen to it um it's
pretty much a game game for that
when he's saying it but uh which which
video here uh the second the first one
is this the white live one yeah this is
the uh the this is the most recent one
this is the most recent one this week at
a rally right
um where trump was there is that the
yeah yeah that's the one and i've got
you uh on the next one for him okay yeah
so you so you uh actually tweeted this
and uh
you said senator john gordon i'm a
racist and then milly miller says hold
my hood um instead of beer then some
but this is this is the famous clip now
where uh hitler i mean trump is standing
behind
uh goebbels i mean mary miller here at
the nazi rail i mean i mean you might as
well just like you know mary hitler is
what you should call her right well
we're i'm going to show you the clip of
her praising hitler not just praising
hitler but she is on the capitol lawn
during the january 6th insurrection
saying that [ __ ] but this is the hitler
lady and i'm going to show you the
evidence of it here's here's what she
said just this last weekend at her nazi
rally with hitler standing behind her
here it is president trump on behalf of
all the magga patriots in america i want
to thank you for the historic
victory for white life in the supreme
court yesterday
white life is that what she said let's
back up white life let's back it up
let's let's double check i life in the
supreme court
victory for white life in the supreme
court yes yes she said white life you
know some people were like oh it's
affording slip she was trying to say
right for life come on
[ __ ] break she totally said white
life and the reason why i believe she
said white life is because of this
[ __ ] clip right here
um
i guess this is the
the last one i sent you is the one
that's the one i think yeah yeah
now she quotes him twice but the second
one is the one about yeah the second one
is the one she said hitler was right
okay well let me let me put that one in
let me put that one in um patriot takes
had this no no the one before that you
just had it well son of a [ __ ] no this
one here says uh trump is holding a
rally today in illinois yeah you can
play both of them she talks about both
clips so we'll just play both
here's a close-up
now patriot takes a post to this
this is the same this is the same woman
who was just standing there talking
about white life and how the supreme
court
protected white life let's listen to
what she has to say about um
a guy named adolf hitler i don't know if
anyone's familiar with adolf hitler but
let's listen
each generation has the responsibility
to teach
in the next generation you know if we
win a few elections we're still going to
be losing unless we win the hearts of
our children
this is the battle
hitler was right on one thing whoa whoa
whoa whoa
hitler was right on one thing this is
really [ __ ] gross like
it would be one thing if you she was
like hitler was right on one thing heinz
is better than hunts right but
no she is talking about absolutely
um indoctrinating children here and
that's what she's talking about and
she's talking about the hitler youth and
she is saying hitler was right
holy actual [ __ ]
ouch this is the lady that illinois 15th
has put in place i don't think they know
this there's no way that i believe that
the majority of people in illinois 15
decided to put this lady who stood on
the capitol line i just don't think they
know it yet they just don't know it yet
they don't know who the [ __ ] they
elected they thought oh yeah trump
backed her sure
you know like that's what we want to do
but but after a while like is she really
so bad
right right right was hitler i mean
hitler was right once was he really that
bad it's like yeah sure he committed
genocide but like
he was also was it an aspiring artist
really genocide i mean would it would a
mass murderer try to also be a painter i
don't think so like that's the here's
the out shot from this rally right um
and you see it's um in front of the
capitol and there's in on the the
banners here it says moms for america
let's listen if we win a few elections
we're still going to be losing by the
way the audio is much better on this
yeah this one is much louder unless we
win the hearts and minds of our children
this is the battle
hitler was right on one thing he said
whoever has the youth has the future
our children are being propagandized
yeah you are doing that to them
projection
you are absolutely
right like oh we can't let them read
books yeah don't read we yeah they're
getting propagandized about you know oh
hey math is bad and insane
it's like don't say gay don't have drag
queens you know you know carrie lake the
fake is over oh that's a good point boy
yeah let's go to that and well that's
the propaganda well yeah this is the
nonsense because they don't even believe
some of this [ __ ] that they're spreading
around and perry lake is the perfect
example of that carrie lake is uh what's
that what's that [ __ ] dipshit's name
with the real shitty mustache you can't
grow a beard he's the guy that wants to
hunt hunt lgbtq community oh for a
moment i thought you're gonna say mike
lindell uh
well that guy too yeah yeah yeah okay
who are you talking about the guy who
can't grow a beard [ __ ] social media
gang that's always trying to get clout
and that he's you know
no no no no no no he's the other nazi
he's the guy that harassed charlie curt
oh i know who you're talking about yes
yeah they're not seeing screens
i know i know there's a long list of
nazis uh hold on
i know who you're talking about uh uh
ethan ethan
schmidt that's it that's it you know
he's the one he's the one that yeah he
helped coined the phrase alphacock yeah
it was a video ethan
where where i said alphacut yeah oh man
there's a good video and i'm not going
to play it of him i i i i watched it
over the weekend of him at like a roe v
wade protest where he's like shouting
into a [ __ ] megaphone and the and and
these women in this crowd are just you
can't even hardly hear him in his
megaphone because they're out shouting
and yeah it was beautiful he was calling
them [ __ ] and all kinds of stuff and
they were just out shouting him it's
[ __ ] fantastic by the way he is he is
the he's the guy that you know and
obviously the you know alpha cuck is a
great title that was given during his
little like attempt to insult these guys
and this teenager [ __ ] whooped his
ass in this argument
well this is the guy who he he brags
about going and and harassing cancer
patients right their mask which is in
your mouth it's like gross and then he
bragged about that
how are you he's gonna go hunt hunt
lgbtq yeah
i mean it's it sounds very similar to
rhetoric we've heard people like uh
greitens or or um there was a country
one time i forget they were taken over
by a bunch of nazis what was that what
was that called i think these are them
yeah it was uh it was back it was it's
been almost 100 years ago i mean it's
been a long time but uh here carrie lake
is
uh
ethan schmidt the [ __ ] mass guy the
guy who was at the road the rogue rally
um shouting at women calling them [ __ ]
um because because they want to have
bodily autonomy
him and carrie lake are great friends
they're great friends but before carrie
lake here is running for governor in
arizona who is an election denier she is
also friends with mike lindell
but she's friends with ethan schmidt as
well she used to be friends with a very
popular drag queen midas touch actually
had a video with yeah an exclusive yeah
with that drag queen and he he was
talking about how uh when when she
performs
uh carrie lake had paid for her perform
carrie lake would come to the
performance they were great friends they
would text back and forth
but this is great because this is fox
news and this is brett barrigan
really [ __ ] stomping out this
nonsense yeah yeah that carry lake the
lies that carry lake is trying to to
spew here watch this is this is
fantastic and that's why we're going to
secure that border starting on day one
after i take my oh no no this is that's
not the one that's not the one that's
not the carry leak
that's the bible one that's even that's
another that's a better one this is the
kerry lake one i was thinking of here it
is
what do you think the most important
issue for your state is
we've got a couple of important issues
we have a wide open border we have
fentanyl pouring in we have the cartels
with operational control but that
wouldn't be happening if we would have
fair honest elections and we had
brown people brown people brown b but
you notice the theme here this
piece of [ __ ] well this is same people
that are like oh this many pounds of
fentanyl were seized at the border
do you understand what seized means
right well if the border wasn't working
then you wouldn't know something was
seized
well
again if you're looking for logic from
these [ __ ]
dopes and and here she's going to cue up
the uh big lie here so let's listen
fraudulent election a corrupt election
and we have an illegitimate president
sitting in the white house and because
of that our border is wide open five and
a half tons of fentanyl was confiscated
last year
it's wide open gabe it's wide open so
much so that they confiscated so uh
a historical amount like right it's
crazy it's crazy we confiscated because
they were like we don't like to use the
see the word seized anymore it's kind of
difficult to understand none of us
really know what it means so we're gonna
use confiscated it means the same
[ __ ] thing right it was there and
they did their job they made them stop
it at the border
this does not allow this this does not
go into this country we will take it we
will confiscate it we will seize it
and the danger here is this [ __ ]
[ __ ] is running for governor
i know of arizona yeah
who
one of the states where they want to
make sure the next time they have a coup
they can overthrow the election there
right because they know it's turning
blue like that's that's their day this
is the same state that was like we've
already double checked triple checked
our ballots it is not fraudulent and
because like county yeah exactly and
then they were like okay well we'll give
this off to a private company called
cyber ninjas who have no experience in
tech who have no experience actually
validating ballots and going through
this who were caught on tape during a
court hearing or uh
uh
hearing that they were doing to show
that there was fraud and actually showed
that their excel spreadsheet double
counted the votes
and then what they found out was oh
actually there were more votes for buy
than than for trump because we went
through and actually did it again this
same group that sent the ballots out to
a lodge or a cabin in the woods of where
the ceo lived this sounds like a really
bad netflix series gabe it sounds like a
really bad network series but again this
is the person that's running who says it
wasn't fair and it wasn't safe and it
wasn't secure arizona she thinks that
she'll do better arizona please please
do not put this person in charge but
bret bear goes right at her lies here
because he knows she's lying
so he he he he immediately
shows that she's a [ __ ] liar like he
well also i mean you've got dominion
coming after fox news so they're all
very cautious about what they can let
say without being the opinion of fox
news dear enough to kill over two
billion people it's a weapon of mass
destruction and that's why we're going
to secure that border starting on day
one after i take my hand off the bible
we are going to issue a declaration of
invasion we're going to finish president
trump's wall and we're going to send our
armed national guard to the border and
stop people from coming across uh
someone in the last clip i said and i'll
give them credit i think their tweet
said the moment i take my hand off the
bible i'm going to do the exact opposite
of what it says
[Laughter]
yeah it's amazing because the other
thing too on this is she says right
there a declaration of invasion
it's insanity she's talking about the
people who are in her state that are
citizens of her state right
that's what she's talking about she's
she's demonizing and
dehumanizing people of a certain skin
color and a certain culture and a
certain background with certain names
names like yours yep and that that are
americans and she is trying to stoke
fear and trying to stoke violence
towards those people by saying it's an
invasion when
really if you if you want to go back
carry late to your [ __ ] history books
and realize that the place that you're
talking about on the on the map was
[ __ ] mexico you dummy
you were the invasion to that area if
you want to be technical about it you
[ __ ] [ __ ] this is all just absolute
ridiculousness that they that people
that that were allowing them to still
stoke fear but watch as brett tears
apart her as a liar you know you've been
down there so many times and people just
pour in and they've got a smile on their
face because with joe biden they feel
they're going to stay here forever and
when i'm governor they're going back
just to circle back you say that it's an
illegitimate president you say that the
election was stolen you speak a lot
about this on the campaign trail
talking about the 2020 election this is
the arizona house speaker rusty bowers
testifying in front of congress last
week
anywhere anyone anytime has said that i
said the election was rigged
that would not be true there was no no
evidence being presented of any
strength
evidence can be hearsay evidence it's
still evidence but it's still hearsay
but strong judicial quality evidence
anything
that would say to me
you have a doubt
deny your oath
i will not do that
he's a republican he's a trump supporter
and that's what he said
he's a rhino just completely tears her
apart and then her response is he's
arrested a rhino he's a rhino he's not
mocking enough so maybe we'll send eric
greitens to go kill him right you know
he'll go rhino hunting anyone who anyone
who disagrees anyone who doesn't follow
the nazi way anyone who doesn't believe
that you know republican is white i mean
right then you have this moment that
they are now the enemy they are now the
sympathizer for
someone who is not white right they are
the person that is against the party
even though that person is like yeah
i'm a republican i have these
conservative values and then they go
nope no no no no no no no no you didn't
believe this conspiracy you're a leftist
you're deep state you're not magga
you're a rhino like it's what the [ __ ]
right tears tears are apart here for the
rhino stuff um where is the goddamn
video of her talking about the drag
queen where she's she's lying about it
and he calls her out on it it's
fantastic
where is this video damn it that wasn't
the video i was thinking but that is a
great video because he tears apart her
lies but there's another i thought that
was at the end of that one god damn it
i'm looking i'm looking okay yeah get
that get the one where she's talking
about the the drag queen and i'll
actually see if i can go to um let's see
if i can go to minus touch
actually i don't know if we have enough
time because that video is too long
go go to the minus touch youtube channel
and uh find it's on there just go to
their videos are you telling people no
no no i'm telling the audience
go to the mind as touch youtube channel
and make sure to subscribe over there
subscribe to our channel too god damn it
don't forget to subscribe to our channel
while i'm thinking of it while i'm
thinking of it it's like with that being
said please subscribe to our channel as
well subscribe to our channel as well
but you know we we're proud partners of
mind as touch here we we broadcast every
single weekday monday through friday
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific on
youtube twitter twitch and we simulcast
to the midas touch facebook page but
make sure you follow their youtube
channel and you follow ours for the
hearings that will continue in july
but if you go to their youtube channel
that video of the drag queen i think
it's barbara what's the last name what's
her last name i forget her last name off
and uh but she's a really famous uh drag
queen in arizona very popular one she
does a lot of shows
and she actually talks in the video
about how she's friends with gary lake
and
and actually did they served her with
papers i guess a cease and desist
because they can't serve her with a
lawsuit they can only serve her with the
cease and desist all right got it and
what they're saying is true
um about carrie lake i mean here is the
let me show you this here here's the uh
here is midas touch exclusive carrie
lake just told fox news that she could
serve with legal paper barbara seville
that's what it is yeah yeah barbara
seville is her name because she couldn't
find barbara this is false we've learned
that lake sent her process server to a
drag show on saturday and served a cease
and desist here's a response from
barbara so this is a response from
barbara there on the mighty switch
and here is ah looky there look at there
i found him
great awesome thanks thanks for finding
that gabe yeah i think you're welcome oh
man the executive producer on it here
here's the part where he tears her apart
about the the drag queen let's watch
this we can't keep having elections that
nobody can live with and we can't have
this level of fraud anymore
understanding that every republican
leader in
washington says that joe biden is the
legitimate president everyone um but i
understand what you're working on but
they're sitting there in washington
they're sitting there in washington
they're not here in
arizona you're running on i get it
journalists to come out here and dig
through this he's totally telling you
one thing
obviously as a candidate you come under
scrutiny the washington post has a story
today says arizona gop candidate who
criticized drag queens was once a fan
according to a giant
fan this is the quote arizona gop
gubernatorial candidate carrie lake who
has attacked drag queens as dangerous to
children attended the shows of drag
queen richard stevens for more than 20
years uh richard stevens is barbara
saville by the way uh richard stevens uh
his his drag queen name is barbara
seville so just to be clear on this
quote i want everyone to know that and
once hired him to perform at her home
and hired her because it was it was drag
queen when she was at her home yeah you
care to address
i do care i actually do care to address
that and i'm really shocked
i'm actually appalled
that fox news would take defamatory
story like that and we are pursuing
legal action against this strike you
notice you notice how bret bear made
sure to quote that article because he
knew she was going to do this he knew
she was going to [ __ ] freak out
because he was probably told don't bring
that up and he's like [ __ ] that i'm
bringing that [ __ ] up well it's the same
thing it's the same tactic of rudy
giuliani and trump there will be video
or photo evidence and they'll be shown
to them
in their face and i'm glad he brought it
up on the actual tv show in the segment
and showed it because then
how she responds i think is is even
better oh it's beautiful
i'm appalled that you would bring that
up when you have not talked about or
stolen an election you've failed you
spent three questions
[Laughter]
he's like
stories i'm asking you to respond to it
if you'd like to
address it but i'm really disappointed
in fox i thought you were a little
better than cnn i'm happy to address
this i just thought that you would like
covered for
decades for decades 20 years
and he's never been in my home he says
he's been in my home for a drag show
that's ludicrous he's never been in my
home he's lied we tried to serve him
defamation papers okay and he's so shady
that we can't even track him down
because he's not even welcome at the
place
i'm sorry this is the last question what
about these pictures of you
what about the
what's hilarious here is all these
pictures and yeah you can go to patriot
takes account because he has all all
this stuff on his account
um barbara seville
um didn't post a lot of these pictures
carrie lake posted some of these
pictures they're all telling her social
media right and was talking and there's
there's instances of of carrie lake
liking barbara saville's
social media posts yeah about drag
queens and all that it's crazy there was
never a drag show i never attended a
drag show they never came to my house i
don't know this barbara i don't know
this steven person like whoever it's
like oh oh this is all made up and it's
fake news that's the approach it's just
like rudy giuliani getting tapped on the
back and saying i was attacked in the
supermarket like it's like dude there's
a video
that shows you where a light light
little [ __ ] tap here's here's the
tweet um minus touch says carrie puddles
does not want you to see this video of
at
the barbara one so that's barbara
saville's handle there
exposing her total fraud so i'm going to
retweet this
so that way you guys can can go look at
that video again it's about eight and
it's almost nine minutes long but it's
fantastic it's a fantastic video you can
watch it here on twitter from the
retweet ahead or go over to youtube and
check it out there thanks for joining us
today gabe
what a what a great day we didn't get to
all the news i know man we really need
like six hours a day
it just piles up and piles up and piles
up and we have so many new listeners we
are so happy to have you here uh at the
tony michaels podcast thanks for
listening every single week day monday
through friday noon eastern 11 central
nine pacific on youtube twitter twitch
and also simulcast from the midas touch
facebook page don't forget to go over to
the twitter account and follow us at the
tony michaels pod
also
you can download every single episode on
apple spotify google
your favorite directory out there go
download each and every episode even the
bonus episodes that we put out on
saturday and sunday we broadcast are we
we publish every single day of the week
we broadcast monday through friday noon
eastern 11 central nine pacific and
until tomorrow at noon eastern surf's up
[ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking